in a nearly three hour movie 58 seconds
of logos movie rips off Band of Brothers
right out of the gate I am too big a
Band of Brothers fan I just let that
slide oh man is it corn I'm so pumped if
that's filled upon there's a music
swelling to match my own excitement for
corn I guess I can't describe it it was
just constant I guess maybe we could
figure that out just by looking at the
movie but thanks documentary be nice to
that miss Hanley she's single well is
that supposed to me repopulating the
earth start pulling your weight
okay first of all he has two kids
already asshole
second of all widowed grandpa suggests
son should ignore looks and attraction
as basic human sexual instincts and just
make babies with the nearest teacher he
can find John Lithgow is playing
basically another version of his Rise of
the Planet of the Apes character an
ineffective grandfather only here to
show us how fast time moves and how
futile it all is why did you mom me
after something that's bad you mean
Murphy's Law well that's only one use of
word why didn't he have this
conversation with her at a younger age
also considering how Cooper will start
driving this truck with the flat tire
like it never happened I have a terrible
feeling this flat tire scene was created
just so that Murph could get a lesson
about why she's named Murph what about
the flat tire indeed Jesus that truck
caught up to that drone so fast it could
only be due to the power of editing
unless you're telling me this particular
drone wants to be followed truck with
supposedly flat tire now drives like it
never happened
anyone else with me on this mysteries of
interstellar how a pickup truck can
drive with a flat tire among densely
planted corn stalks taller than it yep I
thought so
dad k2 insists on yelling dad instead of
explicit instructions nearly Fellman
Louisa's his entire family long after
the emergency stop to avoid following a
drone off a cliff into a lake the drone
hopefully flies by again almost as
though it had not recently just been in
front of them okay so two to two nine
one five and wait a minute the one that
says five actually has six
I'm afraid this girl isn't gifted after
all it's an old federal textbook we've
replaced them with the corrected
versions corrected explaining how the
Apollo missions were faked to bankrupt
the Soviet Union the idiocracy starts
here and despite how ridiculous this
woman sounds it's not that far from the
truth what does dr. Tyson have to say
about this mysteries of interstellar in
this unreal future they teach
unscientific things in science class oh
wait that is real so take opposite and
she didn't want to sit in there
listening to this instead of me which
been a good thing damn it's Matthew
McConaughey's still playing Russ Cole in
this movie does every line reading have
to sound like his larynx is being
dragged on the floor of a gravel library
you should come take a look at this
cliche Thank You butcher sure that dogs
here for shadow reading I'm pretty sure
everyone involved with the operations of
the New York Yankees would throw
themselves off a bridge before they
allowed their franchise to be a touring
sports team like the Harlem
Globetrotters I also love how this
society is dealing with dead crops
crashing drones blight and general
desperation but there's still an
organized baseball league priorities for
the win despite all the cracks in the
barriers on all these windows entire
family feels safe enough to near to
remove masks and goggle
seems like it this kind of storm or
possible one would never leave their
windows open period luckily during a
period where massive dust storms are
common Murph forgot to close her window
while they were out watching a baseball
game and can see proof of the weird
ghost anomaly it's right about here
where you start worrying this movie is
science too huh grandpa will be home in
a while radio without any verification
that you heard this Cooper leaves and
drives off so that Murph can get away
with going on the trip yourself useful I
didn't want you to come on this trip
because I didn't know what I'd find out
here but sure tagged along now that you
tricked me so brilliantly I don't
possibly have time to drive you back
home this is something I need to do
right now despite the possible danger 23
minutes in and movie called interstellar
has yet to give me even a tiny little
bit of space mmm restricted territory
and a post-apocalyptic life written
world F I'm entitled futuristic security
guards will be made from the obelisks of
2001 also
no wonder we didn't see this thing in
action it would have been one of the
most ridiculous things ever to see
one-sixth of a Rubik's Cube phasing and
threatening people I don't turn you into
a vacuum cleaner
no you won't look you definitely didn't
hear that because even I barely heard
that hello Cooper Fisher Brian
I mean Alfred I mean holy this movie
already showed me John Lithgow and now
tosses Michael Caine at me like I'm
gonna have any way to tell them apart
moving forward
that's your Brian can I ask you why you
look like Ridley Scott from an anomaly
what sort of anomaly Oh without warning
sudden wes Bentley in fact this whole
scene is like that sudden Michael Caine
sudden William Devane and sudden wes
Bentley who totally hooks up the rhyme
scheme we're not meant to save the world
we're meant to leave it mysteries of
interstellar can't imagine a future
where escaping earth via wormhole is a
better plan than just fixing earth
you're the best pilot we are the head
and IOB is jealous how amazing this
guy's piloting ability is we need a
pilot well and thank goodness this
awesome pilot just happened upon your
facility right before the big mission
also how is NASA continued operating
blue radar for enough years to build all
this but not long enough to recruit and
train their new modern pilots how are
those not a naturally occurring
phenomena yeah because after all you
need a wormhole making machine in order
for there to be wormholes duh they've
put potentially habitable worlds right
within our reach but why so far if this
group of Samaritans created a wormhole
for us to use why did they put it near
Saturn also doesn't such a wormhole
possibly affect the gravity of the
region did these five dimensional beings
put some sort of anti screws things up
device on the wormhole and one system
shows promise and one that's a bit of a
long shot in one system with three
potential worlds well doctor one of you
could have just led with that then
Cooper wouldn't be asking questions now
would he 3.5 minutes of goodbye
Daughtery so weak after all this time on
the ground and being a farmer he's just
ready to go back into space immediately
we need to get him into shape for that
everybody good plenty of slaves for my
robot colony I gave him a humor setting
so he'd fit in better with his unit
Jesus that's one advanced humor setting
where a robot can sarcastically threaten
the entire crew with his witticisms but
who actually needs the robot to fit in
anyway who's up in space thinking damn
if only this robot could be sarcastic
then I trust it what's your humor
setting tars
that's 100%
and on down to 75 please how's the
computer calculate the amount of humor
it could express in any given instant
its arms what's your honesty parameter
ninety percent ninety percent again
though how does a computer decide when
to use the ten percent total liar
portion of this parameter in
interstellar the producers knew exactly
how why and when you de Chivo G in space
damn this scene - so 2001 I'm surprised
there isn't text on screen stating space
just outside Earth Omaha just a classic
film 2001 I admit watching them flip
switches and doing important space
duties can't be fascinating it's just a
damn let's move yes nearly three hours
and it took 45 minutes to even get to
space can we just all agree that they're
good astronauts who will do all the
technical things that astronauts do and
get moving already dr. brand and Edmunds
they close after asking one question
about dr. Edmunds earlier with virtually
no tells Cooper has enough Sherlock
Holmes in him to be able to figure out
that Edmunds and brand are lovers I
asked Murph to say hi but she's as
stubborn as a roll man Jesus this girl
holds a bigger grunge than that girl in
that movie I can't think of the title
right now but it was about this ghost
that killed people with the grudge a
wormhole and space like this here a
genius NASA astronaut will explain the
theory of wormholes to another genius
NASA astronaut planet is much closer to
Gargantua than we thought gargantia it's
what we're calling them the black hole
this seems like total madness isn't this
madness in interstellar they explore a
planet near a black hole personally I'd
stay as far the hell away from black
holes as I can
yep dr. Tyson's with us on this Landing
there takes us dangerously close and the
black hole that big has a huge
gravitational pull mysteries of
interstellar stars vastly outnumber
black holes why is the best earth-like
planet one that orbits a black hole
gravity on that planet will slow our
clock compared to Earth's drastically
gravity slows time I'm sorry what kind
of drugs did you smoke when you made
this movie in interstellar and in the
real universe strong gravitational field
measurably slow passage of time relative
to others okay we'll remove the sin but
do we have to be happy about it every
hour we spend on that planet will be
seven years back on earth
that's relativity folks casual black
hole relativity will seems just casual
enough to be super wrong in interstellar
experienced Einstein
relativity of time as no other feature
film has shown Welsh okay literal heart
of darkness payment just because
dictionaries are recognizing the
figurative definition of literal doesn't
mean I am less I'm not always well man
how can you tell that from here oh I
guess because this planet is revolving
around some sort of black hole it must
have tidal waves the size of the Burj
Kalifa huh in interstellar you observe
great tidal waves from great tidal
forces of magnitude that orbiting a
black hole might create dam foiled again
your ass back to the Ranger now someone
outside the ship makes a decision that
could prevent them from getting back on
the ship in time cliche I still think
this is a cumbersome invention how does
this think generate the kind of force it
needs to move in this manner I don't see
anything that can propel this machine's
feet to walk much less in water this is
the slowest wave ever it's almost like
it knows the protagonists need extra
time Cooper wait a goddamn minute I'm
sure you just said Hayes Ava's odd 45 to
an hour now I'm not sure if you guys
we're talking about the next wave or how
long until the ship could fly but
regardless four minutes of dialogue with
Anne Hathaway doesn't explain this 45 to
an hour in anyway oh yeah what's
Bentley's character I barely cared about
dad I'll make a note of that for future
Saro 23 years 4 months 8 days wait so
all that stuff we saw on the ocean
planet took over 3 hours out of this 20
minute adventure last three goddamn
hours you've got here's a message is
stored
I get that we like to make fun of the
crying in the scene but damn imagine
watching your young children grow up
over a handful of Skype chats but one
way well you can't say anything so the
shot of McConaughey catching up after 23
years it's just downright awesome and
heartbreaking so we'll knock us an offer
that we must confront the reality of
interstellar travel roll credits we love
is the one thing we're capable of
perceiving that transcends dimensions of
time and space movie drops the power of
love bomb on us apparently the universe
is an actor able to operate only once
someone tells it it's motivation sure
the universe says anything is possible
if you're in love here are the secrets
to time travel also strong female
character with amazing scientific
background to science Edmunds planet is
the best because love and who are you to
say she's wrong
she'll work Nelson's farm I'll make it
up what happened in Nelson Nelson died
walked how does running into basically
what amounts to a wall of ice not do
anything to your spacecraft and this was
a planet candidate dr. Tyson mysteries
of interstellar
gotta tell you Mars right next door
looks way safer than those new planets
they traveled - just what I was thinking
damn movie expect me to believe
three-legged metal robot is somehow
going to climb this I see a steep hill
that's another thing if these machines
like Tarzan case are so adept at walking
around observing collecting data
everything that humans do why did they
even send humans to do this job yeah
yeah they explain it later machine
doesn't improvise well because you can't
program a fear of death but that's total
nonsense so here's a guy named doctor
man and all that that implies - Matt's
on screen and they don't even make out
what a ripoff
you literally raised me from the dead
Lazarus hey did you guys hear that
something just beat me over the head I
can't figure out what it was but I am
woozy but with oxygen and limited supply
kit there really did most the legwork
Kip what kind of a stupid name is that
somebody's kid got their name in the
movie I bet in interstellar there's a
robot named Kip one of the executive
producers a physicist is named Kip I'm
just saying oh damn I took that back dr.
brand I'm sorry to tell you that your
father died today so they're letting her
receive this message right now in front
of everybody
I thought they usually had a time for
that when they went back to the ship but
I get the sneaking suspicion she's
allowed to hear her message because it
has some sort of plot related
information it is more dramatic that way
if a black hole is an oyster then the
singularity's the Pearl inside oh the
equation couldn't reconcile relativity
with quantum mechanics you need more
like more dialogue so that you don't
sound like a big bastard
gargantuan is an older spinning black
hole it's what we call that a gentle
singularity gentle they're hardly gentle
the tidal gravity is so quick that this
is why many were torn watching this
movie works hard to get some scientific
basis for the actions taking place and
even painstakingly tries to make it
simpler for the common folk to
understand but the problem is you're
probably not smart enough to follow
along in every instance you just have to
kind of hang on it take some leaps to
understand a lot of this stuff I mean
points for trying to be scientific and
smart but damn this is hard to follow
sometimes in interstellar if you don't
understand the physics try Kip Thorne's
highly readable book the science of
interstellar you know we have a model
here that the books don't matter but
there were we to argue with Neil
deGrasse Tyson I've already told him
what to look for but how do you know
what to look for by your own admission
everything beyond the horizon is a
complete mystery could very well not
even fit our own standards of measurable
data but you know
what to tell the machine to look for in
a black hole you know why we couldn't
just send machines on these missions
don't you Cooper I'm guessing someone on
the set Bremen we ask the same question
they call that person an idiot fired him
or her and blacklisted them but the
question loomed over the set for three
days before the writers said dammit
they're right let's write some bolt to
explain this a person is still
blacklisted though also you can program
a world-class sense of humor into these
things but not the fear of death for
some reason the movie now decides to cut
back and forth between Matt versus Matt
and Casey versus Topher
I guess so the movie can have some sort
of Magnolia moment where all that goes
down in this family at once no matter
where they aren't I'm its face am I
sitting parallels yeah I'm sitting
parallels I guess Matt Damon turns out
to be evil and I'm okay with that
yeah no I'm totally okay with that
although if you want your sudden obvious
bad guy to be less obvious maybe don't
cast an a-lister like this maybe make it
like Liev Schreiber or something Casey
Affleck is a dick to his sister's really
smart maybe boyfriend in interstellar on
another planet around another star in
another part of the galaxy two guys get
into a fistfight mysteries of
interstellar if you can crack your space
helmet yet keep fighting the planets air
can't be all that bad for you if fairly
and are you say how come an Hathaway and
the other dude can't hear these comms
how does it take this long for these two
to fly to the spot that man and Cooper
walk to a little bit ago doesn't know
the endurance docking procedure the
autopilot does not sense tours disabled
it but you trust setting tars lower than
yours apparently haha funny joke for
sure but earlier tars said this you try
to remember that as a robot I have to do
anything you say
so how does this robot act alone when it
comes to disabling auto pilots and not
telling anybody about it
why didn't he tell Cooper I don't trust
man because XY and Z instead of keeping
it to himself so they can disable auto
docking but they can't disable his
ability to video game dock you open the
hatch the airlock could depressurize
something dr. Mann would know where he
the super scientist astronaut this movie
is made him out to be but whatever
heroes gotta win yo whatever if he blows
here like nothing good
thanks for a helpful and precise answer
wheel and my transmission to the
on-board computer and have it
rebroadcast as emergency PA
Jesus why didn't you think of that
before seems like an obvious thought if
he can't communicate with someone do not
the inner hatch and the message
continues to be don't open the inner
hatch instead of you're going to die if
you open the hatch like this here's why
I repeat do not rhyme so man turns the
radio back on and starts talking to dr.
Brandt not letting her get a word in
edgewise however she can still use the
emergency PA to transport the important
information uninterrupted right what do
you do doc and I have no time to tell
you how that's possible woman that admit
though matching the spin of the
endurance in order to dock it is a
pretty amazing scene take a ramier dr.
Tyson in interstellar they reprise the
matched rotation docking maneuver from
2001 a Space Odyssey but they spent 100
times faster in interstellar experience
Einstein's curvature of space as no
other feature film has shown once we've
gathered enough speed around Gargantua
we use Lander 1 and Ranger 2 is rocket
boosters to push us out of the black
holes of gravity excuse me you're gonna
what the want to push you out of the
what's what now I didn't hear what you
said but it sounds impossible so what
are you doing hero sacrifices himself to
save the world cliche even if the world
is only one person in his current
reality having trouble understanding the
dialogue that's an intentional choice by
the director to crank up the soundtrack
and confuse you but still would be kind
of nice to hear even 20% more dialogue
than we can hear because this is kind of
like a space NASCAR funeral dirge here
look I realize we don't truly know what
happens to a human in a spaceship that
enters a black hole but isn't it
reasonable with the scientific knowledge
we have today to assume that this guy is
vapor according to this movie it's
theoretically possible to fly into a
black hole eject and then end up inside
your daughter's childhood bookshelf now
my question is if he could punch the
books out of the bookcase why can't he
do other things later we see him
manipulate a watch inside her room
so dr. Tyson mysteries of interstellar
if you can poke through a tesseract in
touch books why not just write a note
and pass that through yeah why not we
don't have time for this come on here's
another point in the movie where you
realize a whole bunch of fat could have
been cut from the script the rift
between Murph and Tom happens pretty
much out of nowhere
and then she has to burn the cornfield
in order to get back into the house to
study the bookcase it's dramatic I grant
you but pretty unnecessary it was like
the whole conflict was created just a
dramatic weight and lots of time to a
movie that didn't need it I mean a nerve
Cooper is apparently unaware of the
events of this movie
come on Cooper apparently in the middle
of some sort of three-dimensional
representation of this five dimensional
world tars can still communicate via
radio to Cooper from bump Egypt to
somewhere something's built I don't know
but they constructed this
three-dimensional space inside their
five-dimensional reality to allow you to
understand it well any work you can say
that again
in interstellar if you didn't understand
the plot there is no published book to
help you hmm still seems like a sin
that's a sin right such complicated data
to a child not just any cough an
interstellar of the leading characters
all of whom are scientists or engineers
half are women just an FYI Tommy I'm
gonna find a way to tell Murphy just
like I found this moment how love tars
love also the physical manipulation of
tesseract strings let's not forget that
okay
wait a minute I can see how Cooper is
making the second hand on this launch
speak in Morse code but how is he able
to reach inside the glass of the watch
and how does he ensure the watch
continues to deliver the message once
he's done with it
whoa Cooper woke up on Elysium Brad
because after all I know exactly the
kind of relationship you guys had and
you should get married because you're
both single and attractive alone strange
galaxy and luckily her long-lost love is
totally dead in the future while
orbiting Saturn spaceship security is of
zero concern
bacteria
healthy helps
we'd like to take a moment here for a
special thank you to our friend dr. Neil
deGrasse Tyson for once again helping us
find sins and the wins in a popular
science fiction film the honor was all
ours
it's important to note that we're a
couple of Jackass comedians and that
could be fun but there are people all
over YouTube entertaining while actually
educating and talking about important
stuff and dr. Tyson is one such
individual by way of a star talk channel
d like science D like space you should
be subscribed to star talk
they do great engaging stuff like this
after I saw the movie interstellar I had
a whole barrage of tweets yep
commenting I'm highlighting the physics
of it this sort of thing so here's one
mysteries of interstellar can't imagine
a future where escaping earth via a
wormhole is a better plan than just
fixing earth well this is what made it
literally incredible for me oh really
I mean I never you know as we say in
comedy if you buy the premise you buy
the bit I didn't buy the premise the
premise I mean I know people love the
interstellar I know people that saw it
twice well why wait you agree that we
could have blight on the crops but my
issue was not that there wouldn't be boy
but that why is it easier to launch a
spaceship through a wormhole and go live
on a moon of Saturn you can check out
more of that video below or just click
and subscribe right now to show dr.
Tyson how much you appreciate his
pitching in for one of our sins videos
or you know many of us actually
important contributions to society just
don't subscribe no signature required
well that sounds like a really good deal
thank you again good sir we had a blast
getting corrected and clarified by it we
kind of heart you you are awesome and
now for the outtakes
you will come
it's just that I've never seen you in
here before
I'm gonna smoke everybody involved in
this up and I'm gonna cobble on it
black holes aren't the mythic cosmic
vacuum cleaners of science fiction I'm
gonna find a way to tell Murphy just
like I found this moment how love tars
love I don't think that man can you have
part of my attention you have the
minimal amount the rest of my attention
is back at the offices of Facebook where
my colleagues and I are doing things
that no one in this room including and
especially your clients are
intellectually or creatively capable of
doing do you know how easy this is for
me do you have any idea how easy this is
a joke
like I've been to Tokyo they sell a
little girl underwear in the vending
machines right on the main drag the
Ginza or whatever guys in suits buying
used girl panties how is that okay
that's not okay Matt Damon
remember the last time you took a direct
flight to Pluto it was like a good 20
hour flight and all out our American
Airlines served you were honey roasted
peanuts now you're tired of bland snacks
that don't satisfy your intergalactic
hunger luckily this no longer has to be
your reality eight robots can shoot
amazing tasting personalized snacks
right to your door everyone snacks all
day every day so let your desires go
interstellar and snack smart with nature
box nature box has the most delicious
snacks in the universe that will change
the way you snack it's as simple as that
from my personal favorites like
chocolate banana chips and jalapeno
white cheddar popcorn maker box has over
100 ridiculously delicious snacks to
choose from that get delivered directly
to your doorstep and there's zero chance
of getting bored because they release
brand-new choices every single month
pager box is full of flavor but without
any of the junk just find the flavorful
snacks made with ingredients that you
can trust even better they've got a
smart snap guarantee so if there's ever
anything you don't love let the helpful
folks at nature box know and they'll
replace it in your next box easy and
satisfying so head to nature box
competence now and take your snack life
to the next dimension again that's
nature box calm